[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais répondre à une
question qui m'a été posée à savoir
comment réaliser son macbook pro
facilement sans galère sans se prendre
la tête parce que c'est vrai que des
fois quand on trouvait que ces machines
et qu'on doit lire initialisé par bush
poste comment je fais c'est bien champ
il ya une question qui se pose derrière
qui est super intéressante
c'est la question de vos données
notamment lorsque vous voulez formater
votre bécane pour ensuite l'avant dites
vous bien que si vous ne faites pas ça a
vraiment dans les règles de l'art la
personne qui vous achète votre
ordinateur peut récupérer énormément de
données que vous pensez avoir et c'est
pour ça je m'expliquerai dans une
deuxième partie met tout de suite ce que
je vais faire ce que je vais vous
montrer comment formater votre macbook
macbook pro macbook air
même combat vous allez voir c'est
franchement très facile ont regardé par
ordinateur c'est franchement pas le
bazar est la toute première chose à
faire qui est vraiment hyper important
c'est de faire une sauvegarde vous
faites une sauvegarde time machine sur
un disque dur externe sur ce que vous
voulez vous nous faites des sauvegardes
ça c'est primordial c'est hyper
important
vous allez ensuite dans vos préférences
système dans icloud vous allez sur
localiser mon mac vous décochez puis
ensuite vous voulez connectés une fois
que vous avez fait ça vous allait
éteindre votre bécane et c'est
maintenant qu'on va commencer à formater
l'histoire bon bien évidemment votre
ordinateur doit toujours être branché
sur le secteur ça c'est hyper hyper
hyper important là vous démarrez votre
bécane en pommes et r on laisse appuyez
vous allez petit logo pomme vous
attendez et ça vous ouvrir l'utilitaire
de disque directement pour formater
votre ordinateur
ap là vous avez la petite barbe
progression vous pouvez lâcher les mains
tout va bien
lorsque vous arrivez dans votre
utilitaire os x alors là vous avez
plusieurs possibilités restaurer à
partir d'une sauvegarde de time machine
ça lorsque vous allez réinstaller ça
pourrait être intéressant réinstaller os
x obtenir de l'aide en ligne utilitaire
de disque nous on va là dessus
utilitaire de disque continue et l'asie
mon disque dur
est-ce qu'il faut que je fasse ma vous
cliquez tout simplement sur effacés vous
allez l'effacer et vous allez repartir
sur une base complètement neuve
bon si vous allez voir c'est franchement
hyper hyper hyper simple vous à les
formater vous le renommé macintosh hd
est on si vous avez installé une version
de mac os dessus ou alors carrément
d'installer à partir de time machine ce
qui vous reste alors à votre os à
l'identique tels qu'ils étaient sur une
autre machine ça c'est hyper cool c'est
pratique c'est rapide et ça marche très
bien alors maintenant pour faire hyper
attention parce qu'à plusieurs cas de
figure le premier casting
vous formater parce que vous vendez
votre ordinateur à quelqu'un d'autre
donc ça veut dire que vous laissez à
l'intérieur votre ssd ou votre disque
dur directement au nouvel acquéreur faut
faire vraiment vraiment très très
attention lorsque vous formater est sûre
vous ferme était vraiment bien parce que
la personne en face avec un bon logiciel
peut toujours récupérer vos données
je vous montre un logiciel dans quelques
instants qui marche très très bien ses
records rites de wonder cher et qui
permet effectivement de récupérer très
facilement les données effacées sur un
ordinateur
ensuite il ya deux cas de figure vous
avez été obligé de formater et il y
avait plein de données que vous n'avez
pas pu sauvegarder il vous allez pouvoir
les récupérer avait justement recouvrir
de vente aux enchères qui marche très
bien
tu voudras ont fait ça c'est l'outil qui
pourrait bien lui sauver la vie là vous
êtes sur interface record brit award
d'or cher vous êtes plusieurs
possibilités récupération de fichiers
supprimés si vous avez supprimer des
fichiers accidentellement récupération
de corbeil récupération de disques
formatés récupération de partitions père
but récupération universelle et
récupération de données d'un système
plante et récupération de données ayant
une attaque de virus récupération de
périphériques externes
aujourd'hui on va se poser les questions
de la récupération de disques formatés
parce que vous avez forcément formater
votre disque pour le réinstaller mais
néanmoins on peut quand même récupéré
pas mal de choses l' objet violence on
va regarder ce qu'on peut récupérer adam
moins bien évidemment j pas formater mon
mac
j'en ai besoin tout isolé je n'ai pas du
tout formaté mais vous dans votre
utilisation il faut vraiment imaginer
que votre mac sera formaté pour partir
et à 0 sans aucune donnée et vous allez
voir les choses qu'on peut récupérer
c'est toujours surprenant là on le voit
à l'analyse terminée ok là j'ai plein de
dossiers plein d'infos alors forcément
là mon ordinateur n'a pas été formaté
c'est très clair on va pas se mentir on
n'est pas du tout un ordinateur formaté
et voyons on a quand même et 886 1374
éléments alors il ya peut-être des
choses qui sont intéressantes peut-être
d'autres qui ne le sont pas en tout cas
ce qui est complètement dingue j'ai déjà
engendré dossier c'est de se rendre
compte qu'il ya plein de choses que je
pensais complètement disparu qui sont
toujours là ça c'est un dossier sur
lequel je bossais ou
où ça c'est des vieilles sauvegarde d'un
vieux site sur lequel je bossais et je
retrouve ces images là sur mon ordi ça
ça avait été complètement effacés
je sais même pas ce que ça fout la sas
et les copies de cartes bleues ça c'est
les photos pour le faire par mon fils
que j'avais effacés c'est incroyable ce
que tu récupères ça voyez ça nous
demandent vraiment un truc c'est que
lorsque vous pensez avoir effacé des
infos et des au final ces infos sont
toujours là ça c'est toutes les infos
concernant mon prêt immobilier ces
choses que j'avais complètement effacée
aussi parce que ça montre ce qui est
vraiment hyper hyper intéressant c'est
que au final des choses qu'on pense
avoir effacé de son ordinateur sont
toujours présentes donc c'est hyper
hyper hyper important de vraiment bien
nettoyée de vraiment bien effacer son
ordinateur lorsque vous pensez en tout
cas à la revente ça c'est vraiment le
point essentiel de point numéro un parce
que la personne derrière qui va
installer recovery et qui va faire un
scanner pouvoir récupérer énormément de
choses sur vous l'âge et de la coupe
carte bleue l'ag de la pièce d'identité
donc des infos qui sont vraiment hyper
hyper hyper hyper confidentiel donc il
faut vraiment faire très très très
attention à ça alors ce logiciel n'est
pas vous faire flipper mais en tout cas
ils vont vraiment quelque chose de très
intéressant c'est déjà quand on a besoin
on peut récupérer ses données ou du
moins une partie de ses données et que
si vous pouvez le faire d'autres
pourront le faire et puis ça ne s'arrête
pas là parce qu'à pas mal d'autres
fonctionnalités que je développerai très
probablement une prochaine fois
voilà pour ces quelques infos pour
savoir comment formater votre macbook
pro macbook air comment es tu prêt à
vous donner une fois que le formatage a
été fait je pense vraiment à vos données
ne cherchez pas à récupérer donner
d'autres têtes folles dans ce que vous
avez acheté ordinateurs d'occasion c'est
pas hyper hyper classe et vous lorsque
vous vendez votre ordinateur pensait
vraiment à bien formaté bien vous
protégez quitte à faire une
réinstallation à installer recovery à
vérifier que tout a bien été effacées
pour ensuite revendre formatés au moins
vous partez sur de bonnes bases et vous
êtes vraiment tranquille ça c'est hyper
hyper hyper hyper important voilà
j'espère que ça vous aurez des on
compare à ce sujet parce que c'est très
intéressant ça soulève deux points
essentiels le premier c'est la gestion
de ces données comment on fait comment
informatisé ça la deuxième c'est la
sécurité de vos données quelles sont les
bonnes pratiques à mettre en place pour
être sûr vos données ne tombera pas
entre les mains de
mondo n'importe qui je pense vraiment
des données hyper confidentiel jeu pas
forcément une photo de votre mamie ou
une photo de votre plati lors des fêtes
de noël mais je pense surtout à une
photo de carte bleue je pense aller
donner un petit peu chaîne et pourquoi
pas à des photos compromettantes voilà
faites attention soyez sages prenez soin
de vous dites moi ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire vous invite à les
consulter mais différente playlist pour
vous permet de découvrir les nouveaux
smartphones les nouveaux ordinateurs
tous et tout ça il ya quelque chose
alors voilà d'ici là soyez ça je vous
embrasse et à bientôt
ciao